a new alone in the dark game is coming
returning the series all the way back to
its 1992 roots with a reboot of the game
that helped create the survival horror
genre thq nordic announced the game
during its 2022 game showcase and gave
gamespot an early hands-off look at
alone in the dark which it calls a
reimagining of and a love letter to the
original 3d horror game the rebooted
title is a third-person horror
experience that takes a page from more
recent entries in the genre like
resident evil 4 5 and 6 and dead space
if you're not familiar the original
alone in the dark was set in the 1920s
american south and followed one of two
characters as they tried to escape a
monster-filled mansion called derceto
manor a lot of the things we've come to
think of as survival horror like
dangerous fights with monsters that
leave you feeling underpowered and
solving puzzles as you explore are major
elements of the original game there have
been several games in the alone in the
dark series since the first was released
but the latest game is returning to what
made the original a classic while
updating those elements for modern
audiences swedish developer pieces
interactive is making the new alone in
the dark which also centers on dursetto
manor in the 20s and the original's two
main playable characters private
detective edward carnby and emily
hartwood you'll choose which character
to play at the start of the game like in
the original but this time edward and
emily's stories aren't exactly the same
so to get the full picture of what
happens in alone in the dark you'll
probably want to play it twice dursetto
manor has been recast as a mental
hospital for rich patients as in the
original game the characters arrive
looking for information about emily's
uncle jeremy hartwood but instead of
trying to uncover details about the
mansion owner's suicide they're
attempting to find him after jeremy sent
a strange letter to emily dercetto isn't
the only setting you'll visit either
there are new locations that make up the
game including a spooky alternate
dimension world you'll visit through
portals and which seems to be full of
monsters combat is a major part of the
game and you'll use both firearms and
melee weapons to fight some hideous
twisted monsters footage we saw included
pistols and shotguns but it sounds like
you'll also have to defend yourself with
whatever objects you can grab
you'll also face monsters you can't
easily kill which might mean you'll have
to run away instead of standing your
ground
the game's monsters are designed by
artist guy davis who worked on gears of
war 4 and movies such as the shape of
water nightmare alley and pacific rim
story is also a big component of the new
alone in the dark with amnesia the dark
descent and soma writer mikkel hedberg
penning the reimagined version of the
game's tale hedberg said during thq's
presentation that the story will be more
active than the original expect
cinematic cutscenes and voice dialogue
in addition to notes letters and other
items you'll find as you explore
dursetto manor and the rest of the world
according to thq though the game will
see you fighting monsters and
occasionally running from threats it's
taking a different tack than other
survival horror games while most tend to
focus on a more terror experience alone
in the dark is trying to explore other
aspects of the horror genre the original
had a fairly lovecraftian story with a
lot of dense heavy atmosphere and
psychological dread that atmospheric
brand of horror is something developers
are focusing on for this new game and
while you'll definitely fight horrific
creatures combat may not be the main
thrust of the game alone in the dark is
coming to playstation 5 xbox series xns
and pc thq said the game has been in the
works since late 2019 and is currently
right around an alpha state but no
release date has yet been set a teaser
featuring grace a returning character
from alone in the dark 2 will be
playable at gamescom later this month
and now let's leave you with some more
gameplay so you can get a sense of alone
in the dark for yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
so
you